a Farscape reboot a Farscape
remake oh no a Farscape
continuation oh yes welcome to Sid Trek
your Sci-Fi TV and Movie
[Music]
Channel a bit like Babylon 5 at the time
Farscape was just one of those shows
that was just different it stood out
from the crowd it was well ahead of its
time when it was cancelled in 2002 there
was a massive campaign that resulted in
us getting the miniseries the
Peacekeeper Wars the Sci-Fi network has
been showing this series ever since and
on the 20th anniversary Amazon showed
all four series and the peacekeepers
Wars on Amazon Prime it continues to be
one of those series that people that
really love sci-fi go back to again and
again and again I've told you several
times that in the last couple of years
there's been a big push towards a
Babylon 5 remake as I say a show that's
very similar to Farscape in its sort of
cult
following but a lot of fans don't want a
remake a babyon 5 they're actually quite
angry about it I get lots of comments go
and have a look at any of my Babylon
five videos about people saying for the
love of God don't do this don't do a
remake Farscape though that's not what
they're thinking according to one of my
sources that's actually spoken to people
at Brian Henson's production company
personally Brian Henson is once again
pushing for a continuation of Farscape
now this is not the first time he's
tried to do this going back five or six
years he was really pushing very hard
but actually only a couple of years ago
in 2019 he was seriously trying to get
this done and he was even talking about
the original cast returning then in 2020
there was a ComicCon live video with
lots of the original actors on board
talking about how Brian Hensen had been
having a chat with them trying to get
them involved and how most of them were
very
agreeable but that got poo pooed on by
the lockdowns and a worldwide pandemic
and then about eight months ago there
was rumors about them trying again there
was a slightly complicated picture about
who actually owns the rights to the
series this was a show that was actually
produced by um Brian Henson's production
company Jim Henson's Productions and um
Hallmark in
cooperation with the Sci-Fi Network that
is owned by um NBC and Paramount
and an Australian Network this was
actually one of those very rare things
an Australian American TV show that
happen very often I'm being told though
that that actually now has been resolved
Brian Henson does still have an element
of the rights and so does Hallmark and
so does
NBC they are more than happy now to
start very serious conversations about
this continuation and I mean a proper
continuation the actors Ben Browder
Claudia Black XII Edgley and Anthony
Simco are apparently all had very early
conversations and are all interested in
a return for me as well these actors
have not aged badly in the 20 years
since this show so anybody that's going
to get a comment now and say Oh They'll
need Zimmer frames I don't agree Ben
Browder to be fair looks pretty much the
same as he did well not in Farscape
because he was a kid in Farscape but in
like towards the end of sg1 he most
definitely can still do the action role
but is there a story there to tell well
at the end of the timekeepers wars yes
okay a lot of the main storyline was
resolved but there's a whole universe
there to explore and new threats
potentially to fight against this is a
universe that is full of violence so of
course creating a new TV series
continuing on from where they left off
obviously two decades later is not going
to be that difficult and with Brian
Henson involved well I can only hope
that we will not go the way of loads and
loads of CGI and we will get the
Brilliance of some real puppetry going
on that was one of the joys of Farscape
was that it didn't use stupid special
effects when it didn't need to it used
the Muppet Master to get some of those
effects done and to have characters that
we could really interact interact with
and that the actors could properly
interact with I'm hoping that that is
the way it goes once again because well
if Brian Henson involved surely it's got
to but How likely is this to actually
get to production and if it does come
into production where will you get to
see it well apparently the conversations
at the moment are again between NBC and
to get this on the Sci-Fi Network in the
United States at very least but of
course there are some problems one Jim
Henson and Hallmark can't really produce
a show like this on their own they're
going to need another partner and that
is the conversation that's happening at
the moment I'm looking for that
production partner there are plenty of
them out there and there are plenty of
big fans of Farscape that I'm absolutely
certain will get on board at the moment
though I'm hearing that those
conversations are being facilitated
through Amazon pictures now it will not
be Amazon that produced this TV show but
Amazon have several partners that would
be very interested and they are
basically supporting Brian Hensen and
Hallmark's plans and getting them in
with a production company that can
really do this Justice why Amazon
involved well as I said on the 20th
anniversary just a couple of years ago
Amazon Prime did pick up Farscape and
were showed it and were very pleased
with the numbers they do not have any
sort of Rights involved and and Hallmark
NBC and Brian Henson need a bit of cash
so according to the source I've been
speaking to the current plan which is
not nailed down yet but it's what
they're working towards would be that
this show would appear on the Sci-Fi
Network NBC would be the main customer
but that would only be in the United
States internationally this show would
appear on Amazon's free and Amazon would
be picking up at least some of the bill
for that this is the only real way the
show is going to get made with multiple
partners I'm afraid which I don't think
is a great idea if I'm 100% honest I
always think too many cooks do spoil the
broth I think too many production
companies 100% spoil the TV series and
when you've got a show like this it
really needs one Clear Vision if there
are lots of different companies saying
what this show should be it really could
very quickly lose its way to be honest
fast game is one of those shows that I
think can very easily be brought back
and continued it could be updated in
limited ways even though looking back on
the show I don't think the story needs
to at all I think the story is just as
relevant now as it was then I think the
casting was perfect and can return and I
think it'll be nice maybe if we get the
original series sort of remastered and
touched up a little bit as a buildup
towards the new show getting released
maybe that goes on Prime too maybe that
will make us happy it'll make me happy
but guys get into the comments tell me
what you think is this a show that you
would love to see come back as a proper
continuation not a remake for once I'd
also love to know though is this what
you would love to see with Babylon 5 if
it was possible unfortunately with
Babylon 5 a lot of the cast and crew of
passed away since the production of the
series fast gape doesn't really have
that problem but in an ideal world is
this what you'd want to see from Babylon
5 as well personally it is for me so
Farscape a continuation what do you
think get into the comments if you are
new to the Channel please like subscribe
hit that Bell notification it really
helps us out you'll never miss any of
our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com cidre where most of our new
videos appear first and you get to see
them without the adverts for a small
contribution that really supports the
channel you can also go to c.co UK which
is our dedicated website where we do
articles based on most of our stories
and you get to have a little bit more
information for you to chew on go check
it out as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next
[Music]
time